Speaker 1: OK, let's get into audience questions
for the week, the first question is, David,
why did so many more minority voters vote
Trump in 2020?
These are very interesting numbers and we've
talked about a little bit of the why.
But as a reminder, from 2016 to 2020, Trump
improved six points with black men, three
points with white women, five points with
black women, four points with Hispanic men,
five points with Hispanic women, and then
plus seven with Asians and other minority
ethnicities.
So I think that there's a couple of different
things going on.
Some of it is strictly mathematical and some
of it is more ideological.
The first let's go to the ideological part
first.
I've pointed out that in the twenty twenty
campaign, because of the pandemic, Trump getting
covid the focus being Biden and his socialism
and his dementia and all of these different
things, by by coincidence, not because Trump
decided I'm going to be less racist.
This this you know, I'm not going to talk
about Mexican rapists and all this stuff,
but just because Trump was busy with other
things, he was less overtly antagonistic to
minorities other than the whole China virus
thing, which resonated with a lot of people,
actually.
So that it's not clear that that really did
him much harm.
And so by just being distracted with other
things, there was less of the overt xenophobia
from Trump in twenty twenty than in twenty
sixteen.
There wasn't none of it.
And and you can still find many examples,
but there was less of it overtly, which probably
had some factor.
But I believe that the answer to how did Trump
gain with minority voters?
I think it's actually more of a mathematical
thing.
Voter turnout in general was much higher in
twenty twenty about six or seven full points
higher.
That's millions of people.
And it's less in my mind that Trump converted
minority voters that voted for Hillary in
2016 and they voted for Trump in twenty twenty.
It's that a ton of every demographic group
didn't vote at all in 2016.
And from that group, Trump was able to get
people out in some particular districts, areas
and states.
So when I look at the numbers and we have
this idea, there are people who say people
on the right who say the real racists are
the Democrats.
And over time, minority voters are going to
realize this.
They're going to move to the Republican Party.
And and some of those people are saying these
numbers are evidence of it.
The fact that Trump gained six points with
black men and five points with black women,
etc.
The other side of it is that this is a one
time sort of an anomalous or anomalous situation
and that it's really just because turnout
was particularly high for everybody.
And Joe Biden's margin of victory is what
we should be paying attention to, which was
a really big margin of victory.
I think we just can't resolve it in one election
cycle.
I think that you have to wait and see what
happens in future election cycles.
And I don't think it's completely resolved.
And we're actually going to talk in the next
question about college educated whites leaving
the Republican Party.
Like, are they actually leaving?
Is it a realignment?
What does it mean?
A lot of these things are more than one election
cycle.
There's one other hypothesis, which is one
that the right likes a lot of kind of small
government, libertarian think tanks like it,
which is that they believe minorities are,
quote, natural Republicans, that if they were
more politically engaged, they would naturally
go more towards Republicans, partially because
some of them have more religious backgrounds.
A lot of Catholic Latin American immigrants,
Republicans say, would naturally be Republicans
if they had a higher voter turnout.
A lot of socially conservative black Americans
would more naturally go to the Republican
Party if they had higher voter turnout, were
it not for propagandizing and Democrats lying
to them and belittled all those different
stuff.
I think the I think it's just a hard no.
I think that, you know, as someone myself
who who is from Argentina and have seen Latin
American Catholicism firsthand, it is not
the hard right evangelical Christianity that
leads people to vote for people like Ted Cruz.
That's not what we're talking about when we
talk about most Latin American Catholics.
I don't think there's a natural home in the
Republican Party for that group.
And I you know, the the idea that black voters
only vote for Democrats because they've been
tricked is also there's absolutely no evidence
behind it whatsoever.
So I don't buy that hypothesis.
We will see in 20, 20.
Two and twenty twenty four, what happens with
minority voters?
My view is we don't have enough information
yet to say whether the gain that Trump saw
from minority voters in 2020 means anything
long term or if it's a one time change because
of the particular dynamics of the 2020 election